Lately, the word BREXIT has become a synonym
for APOCALYPSE for most of the media.
At least, the media outside of UK...
There are many things to be said about this
but… today, we are going to focus on this.
“Goldman Sachs to move hundreds of staff
out of London”
And… this is just one example.
At the time we are making this video, 20 banks
have already announced that they will move
part of their staff out of UK.
The most optimistic estimations claim that
the City of London might loose over 30,000
workers…
And the most pessimistic argue that this could
be as high as 200,000 people.
But wait a minute here!
Why is this this important?
Well, if you’ve been following VisualPolitik
for a while, you already know that London
is the global financial capital.
More specifically, that would be the City
of London, also known as the square mile.
The square mile is a city inside of a city
where most of the international banks have
their headquarters.
Yes, even after Brexit, the chances are London
might keep their sway on the financial markets
in Asia or even America.
But…
so far, European business accounts for 35%
of the City’s workload.
And, of course, leaving the European Union
is going to have some consequences.
And now you might wonder…
Well, where will all these banks go?
Which city will be the new European financial
capital?
Well… after months of competition, it seems
we do have a winner:
“Banks and companies plan expansion in Frankfurt
after Brexit’
So far it looks as if Frankfurt is going to
become the new financial powerhouse in Europe,
and perhaps, one of the most important in
the entire world.
But…
What does Frankfurt have that other cities
like Madrid or Paris don’t?
Well, today, we are going to answer to this
question, but before we do, let’s take a
look back at the history…
WHY BANKS ARE LEAVING THE CITY?
The City of London is an area of about a square
mile (see where the name comes from?) inside
broader London.
They have their own laws, their own major
and, even, their own police.
This little space is home for the major international
banks.
300,000 people work in the City, and from
this 300,000 people, 60,000 are European immigrants
who came into the country thanks to the UK
being a part of the European Union.
And…
OK, my dear countrymen, I know what you are
thinking: Despite being an EU country, the
UK never was really inside the free circulation
area.
This means that, theoretically, the British
Government could have closed their borders
to all those immigrants anytime they wanted.
But, in practice, European citizens were getting
in and out of the country as they pleased.
Nevertheless, things are going to change.
The British Prime Minister, Conservative Theresa
May, holds an extremely weak position.
This is despite the fact that she won the
general election in June.
She has lost a large number of seats in parliament.
In fact, it’s not even clear if she will
finish her term...
And, of course, people from in and out of
her party are pushing her to increase
immigration controls.
This would have a big impact in the City of
London, indeed a bigger impact than anywhere
else in UK.
As we said in another video, part of London’s
success comes from their ability to attract
talent from all over the world.
But, if the government closes its doors to
foreigners, those banks who hire immigrants
will have it significantly harder than before.
And make no mistake!
This is not only due to the BREXIT.
In fact, the anti immigrant sentiment in UK
has gone well beyond the borders of European
Union...
“Theresa May to charge companies £2,000
a year for each non-EU worker they employ.”
But wait a minute because there’s more!
As I said, Theresa May and her conservative
party have lost a good share of the seats
in parliament.
And where did those seats go?
Well, they went to the Labour party, a party
whose leader, Jeremy Corbin, has declared
war on the banks.
On his election manifesto, he already proposed
things like this:
“Labour calls for UK financial transaction
tax”
Until now, this tax was one of the biggest
advantages the UK had over the EU.
As you might know, Brussels has been years
debating the possibility of having a financial
transaction tax.
This is the something bankers really don’t
want - no one wants to pay it.
But if UK’s parliament ends up passing such
a law, a lot of companies will be wondering
if they still want to keep their offices in
London.
In other words…
even if the Brexit negotiations end up being
great for the UK’s interests, the air is
still becoming more and more poisonous for
the UK’s financial industry.
And this explains why so many banks are starting
to think about opening offices out of this
country.
But, now the question is: Why are they choosing
Frankfurt?
Well, let’s have a look at that…
EUROPE’S FINANCIAL CAPITAL?
On the very day after the Brexit referendum,
the race to take over London as the global
financial capital started.
For example, in Spain, the regional government
of Madrid launched their own advertising campaign
designed to attract bankers.
Even the Finance Minister, LUIS DE GUINDOS
held personal meetings with executives from
JP Morgan and elsewhere to offer special tax
conditions.
In Paris, Emmanuel Macron has already announced
lower taxes for banks in order to lure them
in from London.
But… sorry guys, it’s really hard to beat
the allure of FRANKFURT.
Standard Chartered Plc, Nomura Holdings Inc.
and Daiwa Securities Group Inc. have picked
Germany’s financial capital for their EU
base to ensure continued access to the single
market.
Citigroup Inc., Goldman Sachs Group Inc. and
Morgan Stanley are weighing a similar decision
But…
what is so special about this city?
Well… first of all, Frankfurt already has
the headquarters of the European Central Bank,
as well as other big banks like Deutsche Bank.
This means, they already have the network
effect we always mention here at VisualPolitik.
They have lots of startups, law firms, consultants,
etc…
Besides, Frankfurt has many business schools
with international prestige, as well as a
university and the second biggest airport
in Europe.
If this was not enough, 70% of the German
population speak English fluently.
This means those British banks can send their
managers to Frankfurt, hold international
meetings, and even hire locals without having
to worry about language.
If you think this is not important, good luck
trying to find the same in France, where only
39% of the people speak English.
Not to mention Spain, where this percentage
is lower at only 25%.
But hold on a minute because there’s more!
As I said in a previous video, Germany is
a decentralized country.
This means regional governments and trade
unions have way more autonomy here than in
any other country.
Thanks to this political architecture, the
region of Hessen, where Frankfurt is located,
can offer things like this:
German labour laws (…) make it difficult
to fire people (…) Frankfurt had initially
proposed a change in labour laws that would
exempt either bankers, or high earners more
generally, from the rules.
OK, but now let’s think about something
else…
If you have a bank and you want to set up
your offices somewhere…
what is the first thing you would need?
Well, that would be a building!
You need a physical place where you can put
your offices...
Well, in this regard, Frankfurt is better
suited than anywhere else.
You see… after World War II, Frankfurt was
totally destroyed.
And they had to rebuild it, almost from nothing.
In other German cities, urban laws forbid
the building of skyscrapers in order to maintain
a uniform, more traditional skyline.
But not in Frankfurt - here you can make buildings
as high as you want.
This explains why, despite a population smaller
than 1 million inhabitants, Frankfurt looks
like a big metropolis.
Further, Germany has one of the cheapest real
estate markets in all of Europe.
Despite the high salaries, houses, rents and
square meters are half of the price of Paris.
And a fraction of the cost of London…
OK, OK, but now I know what you are thinking:
‘Come on Simon!
But what about those corporate tax?
Ay?”.
Well, yes, I know…
Germany has a corporate tax that, in some
cases, reaches to 30%... By comparison the
UK is at 20%.
And you are right, but the devil really is
in the details here.
Do you remember how I said Germany is highly
decentralized?
Well… this applies to corporate tax too.
In this country, corporate tax is divided
in two parts: a national and a regional one.
This means the Federal Government gets only
15% of this tax.
The rest depends on the region.
This means, technically, the State of Hessen,
where Frankfurt is, really has the ability
to reduce this tax.
And of course, doing this might lure more
and more British bankers.
And finally, if none of this was enough for
you, here it comes the big finale: the financial
transaction tax - that tax we mentioned before
that might scare away so many bankers.
That tax, at least in Europe, has about as
many loopholes as possible.
There are so many exceptions on this tax that
even his biggest supporter, the German Finance
Minister, Wolfgang Schaeuble, complained with
these words:
“Even a Swiss cheese needs more than holes.
There has to be something in between them,
otherwise it’s just a hole, not a Swiss
cheese.”
– Wolfgang Schaeuble
So now we have a question for you: Imagine
you are the manager of one of those London
Banks - what would you do?
Would you remain in London?
Or, perhaps you would move your offices to
Frankfurt?
Let us know what you think in the comments
below…
Meanwhile, if you want to know more about
how London became such a financial powerhouse,
do click on this other video.
Also, remember to visit RECONSIDER MEDIA . COM,
the podcast that provided the vocals on this
video that are not mine.
And don’t forget we publish brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday so hit that
subscribe button and you will not miss any
post.
And if you liked this video, give us a thumbs
up and, as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.